my fellow americans
it has been the greatest honor of my
life to serve as first lady of the
united states
i have been inspired by incredible
americans across our country
who lift up our communities through
their kindness
and courage goodness and grace
the past four years have been
unforgettable
as donald and i conclude our time in the
white house
i think of all of the people i have
taken home in my heart
and their incredible stories of love
patriotism
and determination i see the faces of
brave young soldiers
who have told me with their pride in
their eyes
how much they love serving this country
to every service member and to our
incredible military families
you are heroes and you will always be in
my thoughts
and prayers i think of all of the
members of law enforcement
who greet us everywhere we go
at every hour of every day they stand
guard to keep
our communities safe and we are forever
in their depth i have been moved by
children
i have visited in hospitals and foster
care centers
even as they fight difficult illnesses
or face
challenges they bring such a joy to
everyone they meet
i remember the mothers who have battled
the disease of opioid addiction
and have overcome incredible hardships
for love of their children
i have been inspired by the devoted
caregivers
for babies born with neonatal absence
syndrome
and communities that give these children
the support
and care they need to grow
when i think about these meaningful
experiences i'm humbled to have had the
opportunity
to represent a nation with such kind
and generous people as the world
continues to confront the covet 19
pandemic
i thank all of the nurses doctors
healthcare professionals manufacturing
workers
drug drivers and so many others who are
working to save lives
we grieve for the families who have lost
a loved one
due to the pandemic every life is
precious
and i ask all americans to use caution
and common sense to protect the
vulnerable
as millions of vaccines are now being
delivered
in the midst of hardship we have seen
the best of america
shine through students have made cards
and delivered groceries
to our senior citizens teachers
have worked twice as hard to keep our
children learning
families have come together to provide
meals
supplies comfort and friendship to those
in need
be passionate in everything you do but
always remember
that violence is never the answer
and will never be justified
when i came to the white house i
reflected on the responsibility i have
always felt
as a mother to encourage give strength
and teach values of kindness
it is our duty as adults and parents
to ensure that children have the best
opportunities
to lead fulfilling and healthy lives
the passion for helping children succeed
has
driven my policy initiatives as first
lady
i launched the best to ensure that we as
americans
are doing all we can to take care of the
next generation
be best has concentrated on three
pillars
well-being online safety and opioid
abuse
in a few short years i have raised
awareness
of how to keep children safe online
we have made incredible progress on our
nation's
drug epidemic and how it impacts the
lives of newborns and families
and we have given a voice to our most
vulnerable
children in their foster care system
internationally best has evolved into a
platform
that encourages world leaders to discuss
issues impacting the lives of children
and allows them to share solutions
it has been an honor to represent the
american people abroad
i treasure each of my experiences and
the inspiring people
i have met along the way
as i say farewell to my role as first
lady
it is my sincere hope that every
american
will do their part to teach our children
what it means to be best
i encourage parents to educate your
children
about the courageous and selfless heroes
who worked and sacrificed to make this
country
the land of the free and to lead
by example and care for others in your
community
the promise of this nation belongs to
all of us
do not lose sight of your integrity and
values
use every opportunity to show
consideration
for another person and build good habits
into our daily lives in all
circumstances
i ask every american to be an ambassador
of be best to focus on what
unites us to raise above what divides us
to always choose love over hatred peace
over violence and others before yourself
together as one national family
we can continue to be the light of hope
for future generations
and carry on america's legacy of rising
our nation
to greater heights through our spirit of
courage
goodness and fate
no words can express the death of my
gratitude
for the privilege of having served as
your first lady
to all the people of this country you
will be in my heart forever
thank you god bless you and god bless
the united states of america